speaking about voice actors and voice
acting like the only person who's
actually been in an anime here
is you joe yeah yeah i'm like an actual
japanese anime like what was the
experience like for you then
that was really cool because you want to
explain like you're on pop team epic yes
yeah so i just purely by coincidence i
got to voice in pop team epic
uh even though all my lines i did were
in english it was technically
it was technically the japanese i'm in
the sub
i know because funimation dubbed pop
team epic
and they didn't use me i don't think
they're allowed to though
no they weren't but you know
fundamentally you could have hit me up
my dms were open my dm's follow each
other on twitter
you could have dm anyway so i voiced uh
this it was this entire episode that was
voiced in english because pogba maybe
it's just
crazy no rules right um and it was
really cool because
uh i got to voice act with the guy who
voiced ryo in devilman crybaby
oh because he's also fluent in english
he's pretty
good at english oh wow yeah so he and he
delivered obviously in the english part
as well
and it was really cool because it you
know it's a lot of the portrayals
is of voice acting is that you know one
person goes into the booth
they do their lines next person comes in
it's normal that's normally how it is
but
i don't know if this is only in the
japanese industry but
at least with the anime they put all the
voice actors that are in the one episode
all into the same room and there are
four or five microphones lined up
yeah i saw i saw that with some like
behind the scenes documentaries
i think how i understand the dubbing in
like the english speaking world is that
you get one booth
one one one after the other one but in
anime it's
you they do it all in one go so if
there's a current scene
where there are four voice actors then
all four voice actors will go up to the
mics and
basically while holding them the the
script in their hand take it in turns to
deliver their line and when they're not
doing their line they
pull away from the microphone i think
all cartoons used to be that way in the
world
yeah i think recently it's changed i
think so i think one series you
definitely
see that effect in is conoceber where
you can you can tell that all of the
characters are just like bouncing off
each other oh yeah
so much yeah and like the dub the dub
for conor super is actually great
and i i commend them for being able to
like recreate this energy while not
being in the same room because
because you can definitely feel that
energy in the japanese dub i mean
connoisseur
oh yeah that's what makes one of it's
that that's why it's so good because you
can tell that these aren't just
characters that are [ __ ] around with
one another but yeah voice actors that
are just
having a great time yeah exactly and you
need that dynamic in a show like that
yeah and but it was really cool because
with pop team epic
uh you know we would all come on to one
scene you know there was me
you know the main voice actor and then
there was like three or four voice
actors who were doing
you know just side characters yeah and
it was really cool because once a scene
would finish
than if one of us needed a retake or it
was really cool because all of the voice
actors would come together and basically
critique
what we all just did in that one song
that's cool so that we would all come
together and i would get
you know professional advice from the
the voice actor being like
okay that lion deliver was really cool
but maybe if you deliver this next line
like this
then i could respond in this kind of way
oh okay and while all of this
conversation is happening
the voice director is also listening in
so he can put in the input of
um so i mean i didn't have to do too
many retakes with pop team epic because
the voice actor was just like yeah
that's good he just did not give a [ __ ]
right he was just like yeah good enough
[ __ ] whatever i mean like you you
were speaking in english so he was like
yeah this probably sounds better than
right most of the english voice actors
the only time that the voice actor asked
me to do
the voice director asked me to do
something super specific was when i had
to do
the narrator voice uh for the guilty
gear parody scene where i had to say
heaven or hell
like in guilty gear and he was like no
no because the voice director was like a
massive fan of guilty
so he's like no no that's not how you
say it you have to say like this and you
just
boom it over the pr system all of us
just sitting there like
okay i'll do it like that i guess that
sounds like such a fun experience oh it
was super fun
were you nervous doing it oh hell yeah
because
literally everybody else around me are
professional japanese voice actors
but it was really cool because all of
the voice actors were like wow how long
have you been doing voice acting i was
like i
this is my first day technically
speaking this is my first gig
and they were like you're really [ __ ]
good i was like well
call your boy back and then everyone
cheered everyone
lifted joey up
i was like subscribed